situation sanitaire toujours aussi
inquiétantes en russie le pays connaît
tant nouveau record de décès liés au
cours d'un virus à moscou épicentre de
cette contamination qu'on retrouve notre
correspondance des ragots fade
999 des scellés au coc u19 dénombre
aujourd'hui la russie il s'agit d'un
record absolu depuis le début de la
pandémie les contaminations est en
hausse plus de 32000 cas ces dernières
24 heures les autorités n'envisage
pourtant pas de confinement général et
c'est de rassurer le monde des affaires
la situation est difficile surtout dans
certaines régions il n'y a aucune raison
d'introduire un confinement au niveau
fédéral je voudrais rassurer nos
entreprises
le monde des affaires les gens faire
cela serait inopportun car le
confinement nationale aurait un impact
négatif sur les gens et surtout le pays
il n'y a aucune raison à cela
la situation à mouscou épicentre de
l'épidémie a aussi devient de plus en
plus compliqué plus de 6600 nouveau
cadre de corona virus ont été recensés à
une journée avec presque 1500
hospitalisation le maire de moscou
sergueï semaine ils envisagent certaines
restrictions pour contrer l'épidémie
mais ne précise pas lesquels pour le
moment hirter
oui
[Musique]
en général ils ne cesseront pas de
développer la ville malgré la pandémie
moscou vivra sa vie plein marasme des
fragments se poursuivre oui certaines
restrictions sont possibles oui
certaines mesures effectives de court
terme sont possibles mais la ville en
général s'est déjà adapté à la peur mais
gagner et nous comprenons que rien ne
nous arrêtera
c'est essentiel pour le bien être des
gens pour les revenus des citoyens pour
le développement des affaires ces
développements darodes
gravité business
moscou 3 0 plus de 51 millions de russes
ont reçu au moins une dose de vaccin ce
qui reste peu pour une population de 146
millions le porte parole du kremlin
dmitri peskov à lui qualifié
d'irresponsable la décision de ne pas se
faire vacciner dans un tel contexte
épidémique